[Musique]
et c'est l'heure de la page sport dans
l'émission Le 7 8 avec le retour en
plateau de Michel et le midrot
n'ayez pas peur n'ayez pas peur de moi
avec l'actualité de ce weekend il va au
sport c'était ses quarts de finale de la
Coupe du monde de football avec la
France avec la France qui a brillé qui a
gagné deux buts face à l'Angleterre on
l'a tous eu je crois 18 millions de
Français ont vu ce match à la télévision
et il y a eu aussi la victoire du Maroc
un peu plus surprenante la victoire du
Maroc en tout cas on a pu suivre ces
deux exploits dans les Yvelines et
forcément il y a eu beaucoup d'ambiance
un reportage de m'a dit de Franco
qui était sur place
Yvelines c'était à Poissy et attrape où
on regarde tout de suite ce reportage
sur la joie des supporters des Bleus et
des supporters du Maroc dans les
Yvelines
une Marseillaise pour commencer une
nouvelle soirée historique pour le
football français plusieurs dizaines de
supporters des Bleus ont décidé de
donner de la voie au forum Armand
Peugeot de Poissy lors de ce quart de
finale contre l'Angleterre puis soudain
à la 17e minute de jeu Aurélien
ivre de bonheur les pisséké
1-0 ce sera le score à la pose on a
maîtrisé le ballon bon les Anglais ont
été un peu dangereux mais on a réussi à
marquer tôt donc on est plutôt pas mal
pour la deuxième mi-temps
après ce qui compte c'est le travail en
équipe et je crois qu'on a su mettre
l'intensité qu'il fallait dans les duels
pour pouvoir se projeter vers l'avant et
marquer le but qu'il nous faut pour la
victoire refroidi par légalisation
anglaise en début de seconde période les
supporters français continuent d'y
croire et la libération arrivera la 78e
minute grâce à un but de Giroud après
quelques frayeurs les Français sont en
demi-finale de la 22e Coupe du Monde
soulagée et s'est mérité des soldats on
a été combatifs si il se méritait quand
même très content c'était compliqué mais
on l'a fait c'était compliqué mais c'est
ce qui rend la Coupe du Monde
intéressante à regarder mais finalement
ça finit bien Harry Kane il a pas
l'habitude de louper des Pinos il a
loupé le peno c'est parfait quelques
heures plus tôt ce sont les supporters
marocains qui ont exulté dans ce bar
portugais situé près de la mairie de
Trappes
au Maroc s'impose face au Portugal sur
le score de 1 à 0 direction les
demi-finales une première pour un Club
Africain inch'Allah on va partir
j'attends la
oui oui
après une nuit avec des scènes de liesse
aux quatre coins du département
supporter français et marocain se
retrouveront ce mercredi 14 décembre à
20h pour cette demi-finale déjà
historique que le meilleur gagne
on est déjà projeté sur cette
demi-finale France Maroc et Poissy va
d'ailleurs retransmettre de nouveau le
match au forum Armand Peugeot Michael il
sera retransmis aussi dans nombreux bars
ils disent non on l'imagine vous allez
le regarder ce match alors je vais le
regarder alors chez moi pour le coup
parce qu'on a une petite tradition entre
amis depuis le début de la compétition
le premier match contre l'Australie on
le regarde tous ensemble donc l'idée
c'est de faire toute la compétition
ensemble et on est un peu superstitieux
donc on est unif jusqu'à la fin on va
faire un petit tour de table auprès de
nos invités marine petit et Tanguy
fortugel qui sont venus en plateau vous
allez regarder ce match est-ce que ça
vous intéresse la Coupe du monde
même samedi on était sur un ring on
regardait entre deux échauffements là
une passe ou deux on n'a pas pu regarder
depuis le début de la malheureusement la
période ne prête pas que je puisse
regarder un match malheureusement et
forcément on imagine la France favorite
dans ce match puisqu'elle a quand même
un statut de champion du monde à
défendre et ce que c'est ouvert selon
vous quel est votre pronostic si vous en
avez un Marvel j'en ai un c'est que ça
veut dire pour la France aussi ils ont
des le Maroc ils ont des gros joueurs et
tout le monde a sous-estimé le Maroc
jusqu'ici et ils sont arrivés en
demi-finale donc s'ils sont ici c'est
pas pour rien quoi ok moi je reste
français je reste française bleu blanc
rouge non non je suis bah je suis pour
la France maintenant c'est vrai que
jusqu'à maintenant la elle a fait des
expos Maroc
qui fait qui montre les échelons
j'espère que ça va s'arrêter
l'Espagne de du Portugal en face de vous
il y a Jean-Pierre Garcin qui nous a
rejoint bonsoir copilote vous allez
participer dans quelques jours à votre
24e Dakar on va avoir l'occasion d'en
parler mais déjà une petite question sur
France Maroc moi je suis pas passionné
de football mais honnêtement les grands
événements comme ça je les regarde je
l'ai regardé avec plaisir et je trouve
que cette année c'est encore plus il y a
du spectacle il y a du jeu et c'est vrai
que j'ai regardé les matchs du Maroc je
les ai trouvés fabuleux donc j'ai pas de
pronostic parce que je lui dis que ça
sera chaud quand même quoi voilà et on
va parler du Dakar dans un instant un
petit prono avant de passer à autre
chose sur le Dakar ou non
je lui ai dit deux à 0 quand même pour
l'équipe de France je vois quand même la
France l'emporter mais bon on sait
jamais les Portugais disait aussi qu'ils
allaient l'emporter donc et les
Espagnols aussi donc on ne sait jamais
en pronostics
voilà je j'ai tendance à prenait skier
le contraire de ce qui va se passer donc
je vais porter malheur à personne et je
m'abstiendrai de faire un pronostic on
va continuer de parler football Michael
on jouait ce week-end dans les Yvelines
avec des températures quand même un peu
plus fraîches qu'attend oui dans le
championnat de National le FC Versailles
est monté ce week-end le club historique
du Red Star et les Versailles ont réussi
à des accrocher le Red Star sur sa
pelouse le score 0 à 0 classement après
15 juin disputé Versailles et toujours
deuxième du championnat devant son
adversaire du jour
on continue avec le championnat de R3
c'est ça c'est ça exactement Poissy
n'arrive pas à enchaîner après une
défaite contre Vannes une victoire
contre Vannes le week-end dernier
l'épiceaki ont perdu ce week-end sur le
terrain d'Évreux sur le score de 3 à 1
classement la s.i redescend à la
troisième place du championnat derrière
Rouen prochain match pour les Illinois
ce samedi à 18h contre Chartres alors je
suis un peu perdu Michael c'est
maintenant peut-être qu'on va parler du
championnat de régional 3 non c'est pas
du tout on va parler on va parler de la
fédérale 2 là
de fédéral 2 plaisirs qui veut monter en
fin de saison c'est imposé dans la
douleur face à Orsay ce dimanche à
domicile le score 29 à 21 pour les
plaisirsois dans l'autre rencontre
Versailles est perdu 30 à 28 sur sa
pelouse contre le leader Le Havre au
classement plaisir est toujours 5e et
Versailles et la 7e et on va parler
maintenant de la Régionale 3 la région
A3 c'est moi qui avait un problème de
football
très bien alors dans le championnat de
de R3 mortage Wii ce weekend sous les
températures glaciales saint-maurus
Italos et les Illinois se sont inclinés
4 à 2 sur leur terrain mené à 3-0 ils
avaient pourtant réussi à revenir à 3-2
avec une balle de 3 3 ils se sont
finalement inclinés 4 à 2 contre
Saint-Maur dans les dernières secondes
ce dimanche on écoute le capitaine de
l'équipe maurepasienne ce qui est bien
c'est qu'on a su relever la tête à 3-0
et revenir à 32 donc finalement l'état
d'esprit n'était pas si mauvais que ça
si on regarde le classement c'est un
mauvais résultat après on est tombé sur
une équipe qui était pas non plus
mauvaise maintenant on avait un peu un
petit matelas avant avant ce match là on
va voir si si il serait dû encore plus
ou si on arrive à recréer les cartes le
prochain match à la rentrée
merci Mickaël pour cette large page
résultats en continu bien sûr à parler
de sport avant de parler du Dakar dans
un instant on parle de boxe avec nos
invités Marvin petit et Tanguy faroudia
en disait marine petit vous êtes de
retour et vous allez être de retour sur
les rings prochainement Michael vous
demandez en début d'édition ça vous
manquait la compétition de revenir sur
les rimes oui ça manquait ça manquait
énormément parce que j'ai toujours j'ai
toujours boxer de ma vie ça fait
exactement 24 ans je box donc
la box c'est c'est Lançon on va dire et
c'est vrai que j'ai arrêté depuis un
moment j'étais un peu nerveux je le
voyais j'étais beaucoup nerveux même sur
le sur les routes et tout ça j'étais
beaucoup nerveux donc là j'ai repris le
sport donc je me sens beaucoup beaucoup
mieux et je pense revenir très très fort
et là je veux monter de catégorie parce
que enneigé j'ai battu tous les
meilleurs en France et aujourd'hui à
plus personne pour moi en France donc je
pense que voilà aujourd'hui j'ai j'avais
défié ils vont même dit ils vont même
dit qu'il était qui était mon challenger
officiel pour le pour le Championnat
d'Europe
et depuis le temps il m'évite alors
qu'en gros il veut pas me compter parce
que ici aujourd'hui que simbox c'est je
le mettrai ko c'est sûr et
aujourd'hui je veux faire des défis en
66 kg en Walter je vais monter je vais
monter de catégories en Walter faire des
défis en 66 et les mettre KO aussi donc
qu'est-ce qui vous pousse à revenir vous
l'avez dit c'est c'est le défi
finalement c'est le défi ouais j'aime
les défis moi plus plus fort plus
j'adore j'ai toujours mis les gants que
les clés avec les plus fort que moi et
c'est on va dire plus tu mets les gants
les plus forts plus tu progresseras
de ce retour de de Marvin quand je vois
moi quand je le vois sur le ce qu'il y a
sur le ring actuellement enfin sont des
immigrés qui que ce soit Marvin il a
largement sa place voilà que ça soit en
Walter en super Walter c'est malheureux
à dire parce qu'il y a des VDG mais il
peut faire le ménage voilà il a sa place
pour faire le ménage voilà il y en a un
qui est champion du monde un Français
IBA dans une fédération pas mon mineur
mais c'est un titre de champion du monde
quand même Marvin je suis sûr qu'il euh
voilà à Marvin bien près on le sait sur
nos appels qu'un jour avant ça sera un
peu dur et si on nous laisse deux trois
mois de préparation je suis sûr que
Marvin il va avant la limite voilà
est-ce que vous venez aussi pour vos
supporters aussi Marvin on sait que vous
déplacez les foules on l'a dit tout à
l'heure dans cette émission c'est aussi
pour vos superstars je reçois beaucoup
beaucoup de messages sur les sur les
réseaux sur les instagrame les réseaux
Facebook snapchat et tout ça quand
est-ce que je reviens il y en a beaucoup
depuis deux ans et demi on m'a toujours
des messages et genre j'ai dit j'en
faisais promis que j'allais revenir bon
j'ai pas eu l'occasion parce que j'étais
avec ma société j'étais beaucoup pris
avec la couleur de couverture mais
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de revenir et
j'ai envie de faire comme il dit j'ai
envie de faire le tri dans le 66 kg
comme ça j'aurai fait le tri aussi en 66
et je sais et en ce moment je me sens
beaucoup plus fort qu'avant parce que
voilà j'ai la maturité j'ai l'expérience
et je sais que maintenant j'ai un tout
mon sérieux que qui est derrière
votre bilan c'est 25 victoires un nulle
une défaite c'est bien ça c'est avec de
l'entraînement avec des formations
du monde que qui était serré et une
défaite où on m'a volé en Belgique pour
le chauffage donc pour la précision et
du coup vous allez le sentiment que vous
pouvez aller chercher un titre mondial
avec la préparation nécessaire ouais
bien sûr bien sûr en fait faut mettre en
place une structure aujourd'hui
on va plus faire ça à l'aveuglette on va
mettre une structure et faire un compte
préparation à 100% vous donnez combien
de temps
si on propose le combat mais aujourd'hui
en fait moi on propose jamais on propose
pas parce que aujourd'hui vous avez pas
de combat
programmer on va proposer la des
contraintes on m'a appelé on m'a appelé
pour pour boxer et on va proposer comme
toi qui avait dit un titre mondial un
titre mondial pour un championnat du
monde
pour juin donc du coup ben moi je suis
moi je suis partant le mois de juin pour
un titre mondial c'est c'est jouable
c'est jouable on va voir ça dépend
comment il va revenir parce que il va
rester trois ans sans rien faire mais
tout est jouable
peut-être dans les prochaines semaines
le plus dur c'est de revenir le plus dur
c'est revenir une fois qu'il aura fait
son premier combat de retour ça ça y est
la machine à remis en place il reste
plus qu'à qu'à ajuster les deux trois
trucs et si c'est pas moi ça sera
peut-être à la rentrée mais il y aura le
Championnat du Monde c'est une question
de
quand je vois il est il est capable
d'être champion du monde et toute la
préparation va se faire à Élancourt
Marvin pour l'instant on reste en cours
toutes ces préparations après on verra
au niveau des paris
on programme ça moi ce que je veux c'est
les meilleurs sparines et je veux pas je
veux pas disparing on va dire qui sont
en dessous de moi je vais disparaître
qui est beaucoup plus dur que moi et que
je me sens en difficulté et que je sais
que je peux surmonter ça
en tout cas merci Marvin petit merci à
Tanguy fortugel suivre bien sûr avec
attention la suite de votre carrière on
vous souhaite bien sûr le titre mondial
pourquoi pas en juin on va suivre ça
bien sûr avec attention
à Djibril merci d'être venu tous les
deux en plateau et on continue de parler
sport avec vous Jean-Pierre Garcin et je
le disais alors le 31 décembre prochain
vous allez prendre le départ du rallye
red Dakar 2023 une course qui sera
organisée jusqu'au 15 janvier et ce sera
votre 24e participation en tant que
copilote pourquoi ça vous plaît tant
cette course du Dakar c'est une
rencontre le premier Dakar ça a été par
hasard et après c'est la passion quoi
tous les ans on y va et à chaque fois on
revient et on se pose même pas de
question quoi même là je commence à être
vieux et je me pose pas de question je
repense toujours à repartir l'année
d'après donc on structure notre année en
vérité par rapport à cet événement et on
cherche quelque chose à faire voilà et
là cette année
il choisit un peu un défi avec une
équipe chinoise avec un pilote chinois
qui s'appelle goyoud Zang voilà c'est ça
que je connais parce que j'ai fait
quelques courses en Chine et bon bah
c'est la communication qui sera le plus
dur mais ça sera pas la première fois
que je roulais avec un pilote chinois et
en fin de compte 40 mots nous suffisent
à peu près pour avancer sur qu'on peut
pas se raconter notre vie bon même
maintenant il y a des super traducteurs
donc dans la voiture je suis sûr que en
liaison etc me racontera sa vie je suis
pas inquiet mais bon avec 40 mots on va
se débrouiller voilà alors depuis deux
mois là il s'est mis à prendre l'anglais
parce que ce sera en anglais du coup ah
ça sera en anglais ça sera en anglais le
roadbook de toute façon est en anglais
quoi toutes les infos que je donne moi
sont en anglais donc c'est pas trop le
problème quoi j'espère qu'il les a
apprises mais malheureusement avec la le
problème des covid encore chez eux ils
ont du mal à se déplacer même c'est très
difficile donc on s'est pas rencontré
encore cette année on va se rencontrer
le 27 décembre ou le 28 décembre
finalement à distance à distance quoi
voilà distance mais c'est des gens que
j'aime bien honnêtement c'est des gens
que je connais jamais pour qui j'ai déjà
travaillé voilà c'est c'est lui qui m'a
fait un appel du pied ça fait c'est ça
sera son troisième Dakar c'est un jeune
je sais même pas quel âge il a
honnêtement mais je suis pas inquiète du
tout quoi voilà c'est un bon pilote
chinois quoi en tout cas quoi c'est
quelqu'un qui aime qui a une bonne
valeur et ben son premier Dakar il a
fini 14e donc voilà et on voit la
voiture dans laquelle vous avez
participé à un mot sur sur cette voiture
c'est une bonne voiture ouais c'est une
très bonne voiture oui alors c'est un
constructeur chinois alors qui qui vient
petit à petit plus de plus en plus
officiellement quoi et c'est une très
bonne voiture c'est une voiture
on peut raisonnablement penser qu'on va
rentrer entre 10 et 15 quoi à la fin du
Dakar si tout va bien quoi voilà donc ça
serait j'aimerais bien qu'il fasse une
meilleure place avec moi que ce qu'il a
fait déjà ce serait valorisant et puis
pourquoi pas avancer parce que il y a eu
la création d'un championnat du monde
l'année dernière d'un vrai championnat
du monde des filles avec ASO le
promoteur et ça donne un peu dynamique
dans la discipline bon alors ça serait
bien que les gens suivent parce que ça
se fait pas sans constructeur ça se fait
pas son concurrent il y a cinq courses
l'année prochaine il y en aura une à
Dubaï une au Mexique une en Argentine et
une au Maroc avec le Dakar et le Dakar
c'est la première épreuve de ce fameux
championnat donc ça serait bien que tout
le monde s'investisse mais alors même
c'est pas facile mais aujourd'hui mais
non non il faut y croire quoi voilà donc
on va commencer par le Dakar votre
meilleur performance c'est 6e du Dakar
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être dans un
futur proche être sur le podium je sais
pas moi je suis pas imaginer alors non
parce que moi je suis plus proche de la
retraite que du début mais
c'est pas très grave non non les gens
heureusement il y a des jeunes qui sont
arrivés qui sont performants il y en a
qui poussent et c'est très bien quoi
franchement voilà non non moi je vais
rester à essayer de rester entre 10 et
20 ça sera très bien et puis voilà mais
bon si j'ai pas
j'avais commencé à travailler pour
l'organisation du silkwarelli qui est un
rallye en Russie on allait en Chine tout
ça ça fait deux ans que je travaillais
malheureusement avec les événements tout
s'est arrêté je cherche un moyen de
continuer voilà différemment mais bon
aujourd'hui je suis encore en forme
voilà je la pêche j'ai encore envie de
faire copilote je me pose pas de
question bon copilote quels sont ces
missions que doit-il faire un bon
copilote en gros tout le monde se perd
voilà c'est on se retrouve le plus
facilement c'est plus celui qui se
retrouve le plus facilement qui est le
meilleur enfin voilà tout le monde se
perd parce que les informations en plus
maintenant on a les informations
en flash instantanée parce qu'on a une
tablette et on n'a pas d'informations on
peut pas préparer avant le parcours on
peut pas voir notre book c'est se
remettre avant le départ le notre
tablette s'allume avec le roadbook et le
readbook va défiler toute la journée et
c'est un peu notre Bible c'est moi j'ai
mis le roadbook et j'essaye de
comprendre qu'est-ce qu'on fait quoi
voilà donc on se perd ben c'est de
récupérer rapidement et c'est là
heureusement c'est pour les vieux comme
moi c'est beaucoup d'expérience que j'ai
fait des centaines de milliers de
kilomètres dans le désert et le désert
qui soit en Chine en Arabie Saoudite
Saoudite mais c'est toujours le même
quasiment les couleurs sont les mêmes
les difficultés sont les mêmes donc
voilà c'est la chance ou la discipline
permet à des personnes un petit peu
âgées de continuer maths quoi voilà
parce que c'est pas et au contraire un
jeune il a dit il met beaucoup de temps
à acquérir l'expérience et bon il faut
passer par là
il y a une évolution au niveau de
l'organisation du Dakar des informations
c'est le dernier moment bah c'est de
plus en plus professionnel
l'organisation pour éviter le facteur
triche parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui trichaient parce que voilà pour
éviter le facteur triche David castéral
de vos directeur du Dakar depuis 3 ans à
instaurer tout ça justement ces outils
la tablette les informations dernières
minutes on a de moins en moins
d'informations donc on prépare de moins
en moins de choses en vérité quoi mais
c'est bien parce que on a supprimé on
essaye de supprimer le maximum un
programme de triche quoi
en Arabie Saoudite encore cette année
quels sont les pièges à éviter quels
sont les secteurs les plus difficiles
alors comme d'habitude ça sera la
deuxième semaine
cette année on va dans une zone qui
s'appelle le petit quarter qui est le
long de
Oman de la frontière où c'est nos
séances de dunes de sable donc on va se
taper 5 jours et de sable et qu'on voit
la longueur des étapes qui sont très
courts c'est à dire des étapes avec 200
km tout ça ça veut dire que c'est très
dur voilà on a vu des photos des
reconnaissances et tout on sait que ça
va être très dur après malheureusement
nous on passe au mois de janvier au mois
de janvier il fait plus frais il y a des
risques de petites pluies donc le sable
se comporte différemment tandis que les
gens qui font le parcours passent au
mois de septembre octobre et il fait
encore très chaud moi j'y étais il y a
trois semaines il fait encore 30-35
degrés quoi donc nous peut-être qu'on
verra inch'Allah comme on dit mais bon
merci Jean-Pierre Garcin et on le
rappelle le départ du Dakar 2023 c'est
le 31 décembre prochain et vous allez
vous participer pour la 24e fois au
rallye red Dakar on termine avec une
dernière information Michael une
dernière information sportive il y avait
du florball ce week-end à bu qu'est-ce
que vous connaissez le floorball
grégory-ball
Jean-Pierre donc imagine que c'est un
sport de balle voilà ça ressemble plus
ou moins du hockey sur glace mais sans
patins voilà dans un dans un gymnase le
un tournoi de 3e division était organisé
dans la commune de Buc l'occasion de
découvrir ce sport venue des pays
nordiques à un reportage de Gabriel
Gontier
[Musique]
gymnase qu'ils ont trouvé à Luc et c'est
là que tout a commencé pour notre club
les jets de Buck sont le seul club de
flamball présente dans les Yvelines un
club en pleine évolution c'est un sport
déjà qui progresse en France beaucoup
dans plus de villes et à bucocy notre
section jeune et pleine elle a ouvert il
y a 3 ans et les plaines depuis 3 ans au
total ils sont une cinquantaine de
licenciés à pratiquer la discipline à
Buc ce dimanche les jets se sont imposés
face à Amiens 4 à 2
voilà pour cette découverte du flambole
merci Mickaël pour toutes ces précisions
demain vous prendrez ma place pour la
présentation du 7 8 et on parlera de
nouveau de sport avec la diagonale des
Yvelines 78 c'est une diagonale une
course à pied un trail qui traversera le
département du Nord au Sud et forcément
là aussi il faut beaucoup de cardio
comme on a pu le voir dans le reportage
précédent le flambol c'est cardio mais
le trail c'est aussi cardio
[Musique]